bonsoir nous sommes le 11 mars 2015
bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal de la
rédaction voici les titres qui seront
développés ce soir à la Fédération
française du bâtiment dans les Yvelines
s'invite dans la campagne des élections
départementales 5 candidat de 5
formation politique présente pour
échanger à Versailles ce matin avec les
professionnels de ce secteur la maison
du langage de la verrière qui poursuit
son action elle permet d'informer de
sensibiliser et d'accompagner les
parents et puis dans le cadre de la
Semaine femme du monde à
Magny-les-Hameaux une journée sportive
intitulée Le sport donne des ailes vient
de se tenir nous avons pris part au
Bootcamp de faux policiers de faux
agents EDF qui se présentent à votre
domicile et qui en profite pour dérober
vos biens cela s'appelle le vol par
fausse qualité les enquêteurs de la
direction régionale de la police
judiciaire de Versailles d'interpeller
hier trois suspects soupçonnés d'avoir
abusé de la crédulité d'une quarantaine
de victimes en Île-de-France et
notamment dans les Yvelines le préjudice
s'élève à plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros
la Fédération française du bâtiment qui
interpelle donc les candidats aux
élections départementales dans les
Yvelines cinq représentants de formation
politique ont répondu à cette invitation
pour débattre avec les professionnels du
secteur c'était ce matin à Versailles
les raisons de ce rendez-vous et puis le
bilan aussi des échanges avec ce
reportage de Mélanie poquet et de
Patrick Jacques de dicksmed
lutter contre les offres basses
valorisées l'apprentissage maintenir le
soutien financier voici 3D 10
propositions que la Fédération française
du bâtiment veut mettre en avant avec
l'inquiétude d'une baisse de budget liée
notamment à celle des dotations des
communes entraînant donc la diminution
des marchés la part des investissements
en travaux de bâtiment était de l'ordre
de 20% dans le budget précédent je
n'aurais pas vous donner le chiffre en
grandeur donc c'est tout même quelque
chose d'important et encore une fois
nombre d'entreprises yvelinoises
travaillent pour le Conseil Général pour
l'année 2014 le budget s'élevé à 1,2
milliards d'euros dans les Yvelines le
bâtiment représente 6800 entreprises
dont 3000 sont des artisans moi je
travaille beaucoup sur les églises et
bâtiments anciens pour les municipalités
donc et maintenant nous sommes obligés
de trouver des marchés alors la crise à
cette bien c'est que le particulier
s'est recentré un peu plus sur son
immobilier ce qui lui permet de faire
des travaux de rénovation quand il le
peut
selon la Fédération près de 100 000
enfants ont été perdus depuis 2008 en
phase 2 4 candidats aux élections
départementales pour répondre aux
inquiétudes des professionnels il y a
aussi des équipements publics qui sont
dans les compétences du Conseil
départemental et donc là il y a aussi à
la fois à construire à rénover à rendre
accessibles etc et donc c'est avec les
entrepreneurs du bâtiment qu'il faut
travailler moi-même je vois année après
année que notre niveau d'investissement
que nous faisons tout pour maintenir et
quand même sensiblement moins grande
qu'elle ne l'a été donc à partir de là
je suis assez bien placé pour comprendre
que tous les marchés que nous ne passons
pas c'est autant de travail que nous ne
donnons pas aux entreprises nous avons
au Front national beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs nous avons toujours
défendus aux Front national la petite
entreprise la défense des PME des PMI
c'est un point essentiel de notre
programme parce que ça c'est la vitalité
d'un pays conseil général et
un moteur quand il y a des subventions
pour les communes il y a des travaux
faits par les communes avec l'argent des
communes mais aussi avec une aide du
département donc quelque part ça fait
des travaux importants pour les
entreprises à la construction paroles de
soutien la filière constat de la
situation mais pas vraiment de solutions
apportées difficiles en effet de faire
des propositions en la matière quand on
sait que la principale compétence du
conseil général ce n'est pas la
construction mais le social et que les
investissements en travaux des
collectivités sont soumis au code des
marchés publics et ne peuvent pas
favoriser des entreprises d'un secteur
géographique la Fédération du bâtiment
des Yvelines compte 1200 adhérents
pour continuer à évoquer cette
problématique je reçois à présent à
Daniel taravela bonsoir vous êtes le
président de la Fédération française du
bâtiment dans les Yvelines on l'a vu UMP
fondational le PS le PCF et le CNU le
Centre national des indépendants et
paysans qui étaient également présent ce
matin pour échanger avec les
professionnels de votre secteur est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment quelques
heures après ce rendez-vous que vous
avez atteint votre objectif votre but
vous avez obtenu des réponses claires
les réponses claires pas tout à fait
parce que le paradoxe c'est que nous
allons vers une élection
ou même les futurs élus ignorent encore
aujourd'hui qu'elles vont être leurs
compétences en discussion actuellement
on va parler parlementaires à plus forte
raison bien évidemment leur budget ce
qui fait qu'en fait nous n'avons été
simplement confortés je dirais dans nos
craintes de voir laisser budgets
justement diminuer fortement dans
l'avenir on l'a entendu tout à l'heure
dans leur portage et c'est ça qui a
motivé aussi la réunion de ce matin 70%
des dépenses du département dans les
Yvelines sont consacrés au social non
pas à la construction ça représente
est-ce que vous disiez entre 40 et 20% à
travers un communiqué vous avez fait
passer il y a pas très longtemps est-ce
que 14 20% c'est suffisant et comment
inverser cette tendance parce que si on
inverse la tendance ça veut dire qu'il
faudra réduire la part du social aussi
bah non c'est pas suffisant parce qu'en
fait actuellement le budget est
sensiblement effectivement de 20 % en ce
qui concerne la construction sur les 20%
il y a 6 % qui concerne essentiellement
les logements or disons que nos
entreprises nos petites entreprises
puisque je rappelle encore une fois que
nous avons 80% de nos adhérents qui sont
des moins de 10 ne sont pas concernés
par le logement donc en fait ce qui leur
revient c'est 14% sensiblement du budget
du Conseil Général qui va être
maintenant le Conseil départemental
comment on inverse la tendance est-ce
que ça veut dire qu'il faut réduire la
part du social en tout cas faire des
économies ailleurs pour en consacrer
plus au bâtiment personnellement bien
évidemment c'est ce que j'ai tendance à
dire maintenant ce n'est pas forcément
l'opinion des futurs des futurs élus
départementaux
justement quel message vous leur passez
comment vous justifiez vouloir vouloir
dites quoi vous leur dites ok c'est très
bien de faire du social mais si vous
soutenez pas le bâtiment vous aurez
encore plus de souci à la faire parce
que ça va mettre encore
aujourd'hui on assiste depuis pas mal de
temps tout à l'heure vous l'avez dit
dans votre portail nous avons perdu
100000 emplois depuis 2008 donc
actuellement cela continue puisqu'on a
toujours des des licenciements et des
dépôts de bilan et des cessation
d'activité volontaires donc il est
évident que moi personnellement je suis
intimement convaincu que la relance
éventuelle de l'économie au niveau
national ne pourra passer que par leur
lance du bâtiment parce que quand on dit
relance du bâtiment c'est tout ce qu'il
y a autour les fournisseurs et puis
d'autres d'autres corps d'état en
cascade donc je suis moi personnellement
intimement convaincu de la chose
maintenant effectivement reste à
convaincre les élus souvent vous passez
au moment des élections pas seulement
d'ailleurs vous passez des décrits
d'alarme aujourd'hui c'est toujours un
cri d'alarme ou c'est un cri de colère
tenté de colère si vous le voulez pour
être un peu diplomate mais parce que je
crois que ça ne sert à rien d'avoir des
coups de colère ce qu'il faut c'est
arriver à convaincre les gens que l'on a
en face de soi du bien-fondé du
sentiment que l'on a ça plusieurs fois
que si vous essayez de combats
régulièrement et je vous dis au moment
des élections mais c'est vrai pas
uniquement parce que vous êtes actif
pour leur faire comprendre passer le
message et leur dire que la situation
est plus que préoccupante cela étant
vous l'avez entendu là aussi dans dans
votre reportage lorsque vous avez les
interviews des des candidats lorsqu'on
les prend individuellement ils sont
convaincus un petit peu de nos arguments
ensuite ensuite au moment de passer à
l'acte au niveau des des assemblées ou
des délibérations effectivement on
s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose mais quand on discute avec
eux individuellement en général ils nous
disent bah oui effectivement ce que vous
dites est vrai mais il y a toujours un
mec qui est un petit caillou et qui fait
que les choses ne peuvent pas se
dérouler comme elles devraient et s'il y
a encore des mais après les élections
départementales à la fin du mois de mars
vous allez une nouvelle fois les
solliciter reprendre votre pèlerin on
ira forcément de nouveau les solliciter
ce ne sera plus moi puisque moi je vais
passer la je vais faire une passation de
pouvoir au mois de juin donc ce sera mon
successeur qui reprendra son balcon de
pèlerin et qui qui continuera mais je
crois que il faut remettre chaque jour
le travail sur sur
Continuer là pour pour 2015 si on doit
faire une petite projection sur les
carnets de commandes quelle est la
situation à l'heure actuelle alors les
carnets de comment aujourd'hui nous
avons à
disons non pas un surcroît mais
l'augmentation des études mais en
revanche le gros problème c'est qu'on
revient toujours à la même chose c'est
que nous avons toujours à faire à ce que
nous appelons nous la concurrence
déloyale c'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup
d'études mais beaucoup d'études qui sont
perdus pour nos entreprises parce
qu'elles se trouvent face à des gens qui
font du dumping dumping social et donc
il y a mute ça des prix qui sont en
dessous des de production d'une
entreprise normalement constituée et
nous avons cette difficulté là donc vous
avez aujourd'hui je peux pas vous dire
donner de pourcentage mais je pense
qu'il y a au moins 25 ou 30% du marché
qui échappent pour aller vers ces
entreprises je parle pas uniquement du
personnel en détachement mais c'est vrai
aussi pour le personnage à détachement
mais également pour des entreprises
étrangères qui viennent travailler en
France et qui encore une fois traite des
marchés même des marchés publics donc
travailleur au noir aussi ça aussi du
travail noir puisque ce que je dis
toujours c'est que effectivement le
travail noir ce sont des gens qui
viennent de pays de l'Est la plupart du
temps qui travaillent 10 heures par jour
et 7 jours par semaine et j'ai
l'habitude de dire avec l'Assi avec le
sourire malheureusement je dirais c'est
que à partir de 5 heures du soir ou
pendant les week-ends les inspecteurs du
travail ne travaillent pas donc ils
peuvent faire leur travail noir en toute
tranquillité quand vous êtes inquiet
pour la fin de l'année pour la
continuité vous allez quitter votre
mandat dans une situation pas forcément
très agréable absolument absolument avec
des préoccupations mais vous reviendrez
justement d'ici mois de juin on pourra
faire un bilan comme ça de votre de
votre poste président de la Fédération
française du bâtiment dans le
département merci d'être venu situation
vous l'avez entendu qui reste
préoccupante une bonne nouvelle en
revanche pour l'entreprise Renault le
constructeur automobile qui va embaucher
une centaine de personnes en CDI à
partir du mois de juin sur le site de
Flins des embauches qui sont liés à
l'arrivée de la production de la Nissan
Micra les Yvelines premier département
automobile la filière qui représente
45000 postes et 150 entreprises autre
sujet à présent la maison du langage de
la verrière une structure financée par
la ville et par le Conseil départemental
qui permet d'aider les familles qui sont
confrontées à des troubles
d'apprentissage de leurs enfants des
spécialistes qui interviennent
régulièrement première avantage réduire
le temps d'attente pour les
consultations il faut parfois jusqu'à un
an pour décrocher un rendez-vous avec un
orthophoniste au-delà des consultations
ponctuelles de dépistage des
accompagnements de longue durée sont
aussi assurés
l'idée c'est d'Outillé les parents pour
qu'ils puissent accompagner au mieux
leur enfant qui présente des difficultés
qui ont été diagnostiquées par une
équipe médicale ou qui sont en cours de
diagnostic souvent ces troupes sont
associés en a rarement une dyslexie pure
ou une dysgraphie pure sont des trous
qui ce qu'on appelle les troubles
spécifiques des apprentissages donc
malheureusement quelquefois les enfants
doivent avoir et de la psychomotricité
et l'orthophonie
le festival femme du monde se poursuit à
Magny-les-Hameaux samedi dernier se
tenait une manifestation sportive cette
fois-ci le sport donne des ailes un
rendez-vous loin d'être de tout repos
avec au programme un bootcamp comprenez
une session de sport militaire Michael
pensez à bien gainer aspire le nombril
abdos les femmes ont transpiré ce samedi
à Magny-les-Hameaux la Villa organisé
sur l'esplanade du gymnase de l'eau
latelier bootcamp dans le cadre du
festival femme du monde cet entraînement
intensif a pour origine et technique des
camps militaires aux États-Unis
c'est un cours qui se passe en extérieur
en équipe
et l'idée de ce cours là c'est de
travailler un petit peu en comme on dit
en extérieur sur des ateliers en groupe
travail cardiovasculaire c'est un
cours où on est plutôt sur un
dépassement de soi aussi parce que le
bout de camp il vient un peu du des
camps militaires on va dire donc il est
aussi mis à niveau par rapport aux gens
au total elles étaient une dizaine à
souffrir sous le soleil la plupart des
participantes étaient débutantes c'est
un entraînement quand même qui est assez
dur je pense qu'elle a été en plus on a
été tranquillement chacun y a été à son
rythme mais c'est quand même un petit
dépassement faut se dire allez faut que
je tienne faut que j'y aille faut que je
fasse travailler ma ma collègue et tout
enfin c'est un entraînement pour tout le
monde c'est pour nous personnel et puis
aussi c'est pour pour celle avec qui on
travaille pour pas qu'elle qu'elle reste
sur leur faim qu'elles aient envie de
faire plus aussi de se donner très
fatigant éreintant c'est vraiment un
vrai dépassement de soi surtout quand on
fait ça pas le samedi matin on est un
peu fatigué donc les débuts étaient très
très difficiles pour moi j'étais
vraiment exténuée puis après ça a été
à la fin de la séance les participants
n'ont pas regretté une seule seconde d'y
avoir participé je trouve que pour une
commune c'est vraiment très sympa
d'organiser ça pour la journée de la
femme ça permet d'avoir une journée à
nous ou justement on laisse un petit peu
le marrer les enfants à la maison et on
se dit bah on pense à toi à nous on y va
avec des copines et c'est notre vie René
à nous quoi vu le succès rencontré par
cette activité cette année l'atelier
bootcamp devrait être reconduit l'an
prochain pour l'édition 2016 du festival
fin du monde
prochain point sur la formation locale
demain jeudi sur tvfils dans un instant
nouvelle édition de kiosque le magazine
de la culture avec Catherine zulato très
belle soirée